[Music]
you burn the suit you're not rob any
more so what now being Hawk and Dove was
dangerous for both of us I stopped but
if you can't we're done you're asking me
to choose between my destiny and you
maybe they're the same thing
I'm sorry
and your little experiment mama won't
burn this place down myself
there's ghosts in this place tell them
what happened
look I don't take orders of you anymore
man get out of my way you're in my way
would you do it again vote all that time
and trouble for someone who just wants
to leave
I would do everything exactly the same
I'm not sure if it's the right thing to
do and I think you have a choice you
ready for this Grayson yep
what is the deal with you and shimmer
anyway
[Music]
well first her name is shimmer that's
just annoying okay crystal
and I guess I'm Connor
now what the hell is this place anyway
this is a place where people like you
can learn how to be the best version of
who you are I hope I haven't broken this
place know won't miss corriander who
else - they said just sorry about that
your highness
I'm glad you could make it the sweet
Wilson's why we shuttered this place
[Applause]
sooner or later he'll come knocking he's
gonna kill how many more now
now's the time to be Peppa
[Music]
everybody is Charlie they dropped the
official tighten season 2 trailer we got
a whole bunch of Batman whole bunch of
Deathstroke the rolling really hard on
Red Hood and compelling Nightwing to
become Batman I love that little tag at
the end of the trailer be Batman so
we'll break it all down there's a new
round of that DC Universe giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Titan
Season 2 theory on the video there's
actually a couple lines of dialogue
during this trailer that confirm a
couple big fan theories about what
happened to the original version of the
Titans and what caused them to break up
basically blaming Deathstroke for
probably killing one of the members
pretty good odds that winds up being
Aqualad because we don't see him
anywhere in present-day you get some
flashbacks with Wonder Girl Donna Troy
you're asking me to choose between you
and my Destiny's so it sounds like he
wanted to quit the original version of
the Titans when things were getting a
little too real
but because Wonder Woman was grooming
her to eventually take her place some
day early stand in for her in a lot of
things around the world that Wonder
Woman doesn't have time for she didn't
want to go with him the early prediction
Deathstroke probably wound up killing
him just completely driving the team
apart because when we see them during
season 1 where they start reconnecting
you get that there's all this weird bad
blood that they never really fully
explained but that seems like what
they're doing this season they're also
ruined really hard on terrible dads
Batman as a terrible dad in Deathstroke
is an even worse dad so Batman isn't all
bad like I wouldn't say he's the worst
dad in the world but there been a lot of
comics in the last couple of years that
have tried to address the issue of why
he would take children off the street
and put them into this life like why
would you compel a child to become Robin
why would you endorse that kind of
lifestyle for them and I love iane
Glen's version of Bruce Wayne saying
that I would do it all over again in the
trailer when the question is asked to
him would you do this all over again yes
I absolutely would they start with a
really quick montage of all the
characters you get another shot of
Superboy and Krypto we saw in the last
trailer then they sort of get to the
meat of the actual footage I love the
idea that Jason Todd is just standing in
the wreckage of one of the bat caves
here like what just happened what the
hell is going on because at the end of
season 1 Trigon had Nightwing in that
special mind space where he was trying
to corrupt him so that's probably where
a lot of this environmental destruction
is from early in the trailer before the
sort of get to the later episodes
footage this is Jericho one of
Deathstroke's other children he's gonna
be a big part of the season along with
ravager the female version of ravager
Rose Wilson she obviously goes full
comic book Ravager I don't know exactly
what they're gonna do with Jericho this
season and if he'll get a costume too
the whole thing about hawk wanting Doug
to stop being dove is the same reason
why Nightwing wanted to stop being Robin
so he wanted to leave Batman because it
was getting a little too real and he was
worried that he was gonna turn into this
terrible person or wind up dying last
season a lot of you were like hey wait a
minute didn't dev wind up dying how did
she show up in the season 2 trailer
she just got her ass beat so bad by
trigons people that she was in the
hospital for the rest of the season
Raven breaking down with the gem in her
forehead obviously is happening after
the first episode because it seems like
that's when that happens she wants a
trapping Trigon in the gem saving her
friends and then has to just deal with
that for the rest of her existence but
it's this constant dark presence
weighing on her at all times
which gives you a little context for why
she's so dark all the time imagine the
worst person possible just whispering in
your ear at all times to release them
she can actually sense what's going on
with her father while he's in the gem at
all times this is another shot of the
Titans tower it looks like present-day I
love the idea that does like I will burn
this place to the ground if you try to
put the Titans back together but very
clearly they're putting a new Titans
team together more of Jason Todd is
going completely gung-ho I love the idea
that he's the one that alerts
Deathstroke that the Titans are getting
back together Titans are back [ __ ]
and all the sudden you have Deathstroke
has been chilling out for the last
couple of years who sees an opportunity
to take them down again the real
question though is why did he kill
Aqualad or one of the other potential
members and why is he after them in
present day probably has something to do
with his children with Ravager and
Jericho but I love the foreshadowing in
this - there's a theory that he's gonna
be the person that winds up killing
Jason Todd putting him on that Red Hood
Ark obviously he's got to be in the
ground for a little while before he can
throw him in a Lazarus Pit and bring him
back as the Red Hood character but it
seems like him being so brazen in public
about the Titans coming back just for
shadows Deathstroke eventually killing
him we get our Robin Nightwing Batman
scene
I love the
eeeh that he's going to help him on the
path to becoming Nightwing not only just
bankrolling him and give him the actual
physical Nightwing costume but talking
him through the process of why it's
necessary for him and why he should
become Nightwing because that's why they
included that scene of him burning his
Robin costume last season during season
1 we all assumed he was gonna get his
costume in the finale but then they
cancelled that last episode and just
sort of recut it with some new footage
turning it into episode 1 of season 2 so
a lot of the times when you see him in
the Robin costume in this trailer it's
flashbacks to the original version of
the Titans however many years ago before
they broke up loved the playful banter
between Raven and Nightwing she sort of
gives him the idea like yeah you don't
have a choice in this you definitely
have to put this Titans team together
you can also see some of the Batcave
architecture in the background here too
and when we got those season 1 scenes in
the Batcave even though it's all
happening inside Robins head or it's a
flashback that's what the actual Batcave
looks like that's what the actual
Batmobile looks like but I think the
idea is obviously Batman is constantly
upgrading his arsenal so we might see a
couple different versions of the
Batmobile
this is a scene from one of the second
or third episodes I think with Starfire
and Nightwing inside the Titans Tower
don't know if it's gonna be in San
Francisco or if they're gonna have some
other explanation for it because during
season one they traveled all over mostly
what was the East Coast in the Midwest
we didn't see them too much over on the
west coast new scene of Nightwing
training Beast Boy and hand-to-hand
combat them sparring I'm sure there'll
be some funny moments where they're
sparring and he just hooks out into
animal form love all the sick burns that
Donna Troy lays on shimmer we finally
explained who this character is we saw a
little bit of footage of this fight in
the last trailer but it was really far
away so it was kind of hard to tell who
they were fighting like dr. light shows
up later in the trailer she's just been
a minor comic book villain that's been a
thorn in her side for a long time she's
from The Wonder Woman comics she'll just
be someone for her to lay the massive
beatdown on during the season we finally
get to see Conner Kent Superboy used
some of his powers there's a lot more
footage of him during this trailer with
Krypto him rescuing him him getting the
black and red Conner Kent Superboy
t-shirt from the comics from us stand no
coincidence the Superman merch is all
over the place there's a big rumor
they're going to have a Superman cameo
during the season two as part of his
story arc which makes sense you
introduced Conner Kent super
boy who's a clone of Superman you have
to introduce Superman at some point no
idea which actor they would get to play
that because we have a couple different
versions of Superman coming to crisis on
Infinite Earths this season Brandon Roth
playing the kingdom comes Superman which
will kind of twist your head in knots
because he was sort of playing a future
version of Christopher Reeve Superman so
it's sort of like saying the Christopher
Reeves Superman eventually became
Kingdom Come Superman but that's sort of
happening in a separate universe there
been rumors about titans possibly
crossing over into crisis on Infinite
Earths but none of that's been confirmed
so for now I just assuming that they're
completely separate universes this is
another shot of that classic Titans team
then we have a new shot and present-day
in the Titans Tower of ravager with
Nightwing this seems like it's happening
right after whatever assault is
happening here where she's taking down
those cops that probably tried to
apprehend her right after apparently
whatever happens to take her eye out
because you still got that bandage on so
she's still recovering but then she
makes the joke about hope I don't break
this place obviously foreshadowing Teen
Titans the Judas contract story which
Geoff Johns said they would get to in a
future season I talked about it in the
last trailer but odds are what they'll
do is they'll just use her as the Terra
like she will eventually betray the team
to her father Deathstroke cool training
scene with Robin and Ravager she's been
trained by Deathstroke that's why she's
so much more badass than the other
members of the Titans we finally get
some of the Starfire backstory she
talked a little bit about where she came
from and her home planet during season
one but it was a very very brief scene
this is probably just her sisters men
black fire coming to take her back home
in Chains because there's this whole
game of Thrones backstory between the
two of them her sister wants to take the
throne and take control of the planet
but Starfire is technically ahead of her
in the line of succession so we'll see
how crazy they get with that this season
but because Starfire is a character from
outer space a lot of the aliens showing
up during season two will be through her
storyline then we get our big dr. light
scene they're actually doing the male
version of dr. light they did the female
version on the flash a couple seasons
ago I don't know which episode he shows
up in but they're probably setting him
up for a really satisfying takedown
because that's the way most of the
comics have been using him just because
he's such an awful awful person and
obviously if you didn't know before Esai
Morales
is playing the new version of
Deathstroke so this is what his costume
looks like we got kind of a darker look
at it in that last trailer this is a
much better look in broad daylight and
went on at Roy is talking to Robin
saying be Batman I don't think she's
speaking literally like don't take the
mantle of the bat because that is a big
comic book Easter egg that wing did
become Batman for a while but everybody
poster Titans season two theories in the
comments below
obviously it's probably gonna be season
three before we get the full culmination
of the Judas contract storyline there is
a new joke or trailer dropping tomorrow
morning so of course I'll do a video for
that but click here to learn about
what's going on with spider-man Marvel
in Sony and click here for my Star Wars
Episode nine trailer Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight